oh yes I'd like one black hooker one
asian hooker and a possible transvestite
but I want to be able to return her if
I'm not in the mood there you go sum up
the whole movie for you three hours of
just that the wolf of Wall Street's the
most intense [ __ ] movie ever not
really I waited a long ass time to watch
this movie it's Scorsese or Scorsese for
you [ __ ] [ __ ] out there anyway
Scorsese and DiCaprio pairing is one of
my favorite teams of Hollywood and this
is not like anything they've ever done
before all the stuff they've done before
has departed this film took such new
flights it was like an aviator was
writing the airplane some like shutter
island' Heather it's like a party movie
this film it's like Spring Breakers
meets Goodfellas this film is just
debauchery upon debauchery if this movie
is accurate - the true story
I'm surprised Jordan Bellefonte or
whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ] name is
did not die Belfort it's Belfort it's
just non-stop greed drugs and sex with
hookers that's I'm sure you can tell by
my hilarious opening right off the bat
this film is owned by one person that of
course being Leonardo death [ __ ] he
is one of my all-time favorite actors it
just has such contagious energy and
intensity like whenever I get in an
intense mood I channel my Leonardo da
[ __ ] Caprio so you want me to channel
my Leonardo DiCaprio impression that's
what you want me to do
who the [ __ ] are you you have to be a
real DiCaprio fantasy what I was going
for anyway you plays the wolf of
wallstreet a man came from nothing and
they made millions and millions of
dollars by doing a legal [ __ ] well being
non-stop 3d sorting incredible amounts
of cocaine taking a bunch of illegally
prescribed drugs and [ __ ] some really
hot hookers like when you think about
hookers in real life that's disgusting
but if this is a true story man there
are some really hot hookers out there
that I would not mind but it knows the
money boy anyway DiCaprio is such a
strong amount of death to the
performance it is so raw it is not
medium rare it is not well done is raw
I thought that would be funnier we do
understand do anything this crazy before
like there's real sex scenes with
Leonardo DiCaprio
you can watch DiCaprio [ __ ] in this
movie it's kind of like what maybe you
really have sex like in real life like
the second scene he's blowing cocaine
into a girl's [ __ ] that's the second
scene they you know Leonardo DiCaprio
wanted a blow cocaine up in my [ __ ] I
let him do it might even for some dude
and it's not like this movie starts off
crazy and then just gets less crazy as
it goes this movie starts off batshit
insane and just gets more batshit insane
it's like batshit everywhere he's
totally believable as this drug-crazed
sex addict but yet successful
entrepreneur or entrepreneur or I don't
give a [ __ ] how you announce it wild
performance in my opinion the best
performance of the year and if he
doesn't get it
well then that black guy better unit and
Jonah Hill has DiCaprio's number two
he's like how Spock is to Kirk how dr.
Watson is to Sherlock Holmes like how
short round is to Indiana Jones got the
job
if you thought his dramatic turn in
Moneyball was great you ain't seen
nothing yet mother yes another wild
character
appears into this role it's not just cuz
it was Heron teeth you might believe
this guy like is he funny yeah he's
funny but not in the same way how he is
not all it's Apatow films or Apatow or
let's not do this again came in DiCaprio
have magical chemistry together like
Hogwarts cats you really see them as
best buds and minor spoiler alert you
see a dick in the film Oh totally suck
Jonah Hill's fat dick the entire cast is
fantastic DiCaprio's character has two
wives in this film not at the same time
he divorces one of them and then leaves
that ugly [ __ ] for a wetter [ __ ] that
second wife is so [ __ ] hot but at one
point you see her butt naked I'm talking
crotch and everything Holy Mother of God
I did not believe that angel I was
looking at it's like Jesus Christ had
bestowed upon us a great gift it's hot
Atlee dicaprio comes in 11 seconds when
he's funnier if it were me I would come
before penetration plan she's a great
actress should probably mention that and
yes yes
honestly this film is also worth
watching for this man who had less than
10 minutes of screen time Matthew
McConaughey it's more of a cameo than a
supporting role but did you Roxy he's
like DiCaprio's first mentor in a way
then when he's on screen he is all you
want to watch he does look a little
weird in the film though he's like
tanned and super skinny with an
interesting haircut so it doesn't look
so sexy
which makes me question everything I
feel about his performance and of course
the legendary directing by Martin
Scorsese is say Z [ __ ] you this man by
far is the most consistent director we
have ever had he immerses you into this
psychotic world into this like excessive
lifestyle like it's a raw film he's
three hours but it feels like the most
entertaining three hours ever people are
getting upset about this film saying
that it glorifies all the bad things
that Jordan Belfort did i 100% disagree
if you want that if it's something like
I want to be this guy then something is
seriously [ __ ] up with you man you
should seek some counseling this is the
only Scarface where it inspires you
don't want to be a gangster
this isn't like Ben Affleck and boiler
room that makes you go I'm gonna be a
badass rich [ __ ]
something you watch Rob Schneider
the hot chick yeah the Cabrio gets the
nice car the nice house and all the hot
[ __ ] but as the phone progressively
goes it gets darker you totally get how
all this [ __ ] he's done is just so bad
for someone when I saw the trailer I
thought it's gonna be like some really
fun movie like a catch me if you can't
have a vibe where you know the fun is
all about the con and the conceit this
felt totally different it's about the
lifestyle these people lived just the
crazy lifestyle and what greed has done
to them that's why greed is one of the
seven deadly sins so is lust
so it's gluttony but lord knows I love
to being a fat chick so I felt a little
bit more it could have been trimmed down
somewhere between 15 to 30 minutes could
have gone just some of these scenes
going a little bit too long it's like I
get it's about access I totally
understand that but after a while it's
like yeah dude I get it DiCaprio loves
drugs and he loves hanging out with his
boys and he loves being in a bunch of
hookers the film was absolutely wild and
raw
it's another Scorsese or Scorsese or I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm gonna punch you in
the face classic let me get straight to
the point here oh and all I gotta say
the wolf of Wall Street got it super
right
alright guys these are checking on my
review for the wolf of Wall Street
aren't you go ahead scroll that comment
box below and tell me who's asked would
you blow cocaine into anybody more
episodes of straight to the point with
me BAM hit this little box watch more of
my stuff a minute
how many critics are this sexy last not
least of you I get up in it every time
one of my reviews its outgoing thought
it was one of my my dick to subscribe
that's right the dick or as I call it
the wolf of ball Street
[Music]